one of Russia's few allies emerged with
a proposal to end the war
China is willing to play a constructive
role in politically resolving the
Ukrainian crisis Beijing announced
instead of sharing its vast military
might with Russia
China wants to broker a comprehensive
ceasefire have peace talks and see an
immediate end to all sanctions on its
Ally Russia so we will look at the
principles of course but we will look at
them against the backdrop that China has
taken sites indeed China is no neutral
Observer Beijing refuses to condemn the
Russian invasion and maintains a
partnership Without Limits with Moscow
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
said he would still like to meet with
China's Xi Jinping in the future I think
that would be useful to our countries
and to Global Security
Ukraine says any peace plan must start
with the complete withdrawal of Russian
troops one year ago at the U.N security
Council western allies quickly rejected
China's proposal members of this Council
should not fall into the false
equivalency
of calling on both sides to stop
fighting no member of this Council
should call up for peace while
supporting Russia's war on Ukraine and
on the U.N Charter with its plan Beijing
seems to be sending a message respecting
Ukraine's sovereignty means respecting
China's too especially when it comes to
the future of Taiwan and the growing U.S
military presence on China's doorstep
some country while stressing sovereignty
and territory Integrity on the Ukraine
issue is blatantly interfering other
countries Internal Affairs and
undermining their sovereignty and
territory Integrity China and Russia are
both clear they want a new multi-polar
world one that counters the power of the
US and NATO
caught in the middle is Ukraine where
the year-long war is increasingly a
battle for the future Global Order
Jackson prosco Global News Washington